[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir haben diese protokolle verfasst das
sind
[Musik]
dieser satz
der rest hat wie gut dass das ist so
schlimm geschrieben oder
[Musik]
wieso das denn das
gelang tisch
wer hat augen
hintergrund hat aber einfach mit lachs
aus luft steckt
jahrzehnte lang hat die welt gerätselt
was hat eine kleine zuger firma namens
crypto ag mit ausländischen
geheimdiensten zu tun mit der cia mit
der nsa dem deutschen bnd
nun deckt ein geheimdienst dass hier
eine globale operation einer
unglaublichen dimension auf das dokument
heißt minerva und stammt aus dem archiv
der ce
[Musik]
es war gleichzeitig das produktivste und
längste spionage projekt seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg
das ist schlicht die wichtigste spionage
operation die jemals stattgefunden hat
doch mitte der 90er jahre bringt dieser
man die groß angelegte spionage
operation fast zu fall
[Musik]
die verhaftung der schweizer
geschäftsmannes hans bühler in iran
belastet hans bühler top verkäufer der
firma kryptologie neun monate sitzt er
in einem iranischen gefängnis
die bühne affäre schlitterte langsam von
einer chaotischen persönlichen
angelegenheit in eine gegenspionage
katastrophe
sie verschlüsselt vor der bescherung wir
werden sie jetzt eine dritte tietz
mittagessen in jenen tagen aus klemmen
die rundschau ist nah dran an der affäre
bühler sie haben also nun gar nichts an
gut mit nachrichtendiensten nur als
kunden natürlich kann aber keine beweise
liefern von manipulationen kann keine
rede sein
manipulation kann nur jemand behaupten
der sehr naiv diesen dingen gegenüber
steht unsere geräte sind nicht
manipulierbar
nachdem rundschau interview atmen die
ausländischen geheimdienste auf fast
wäre alles aufgeflogen es war knapp sehr
knapp die operation läuft weiter
die geschichte beginnt mit dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs die nazis sind
besiegt die amerikaner hatten einen
wichtigen vorteil sie waren den nazis
immer einen schritt voraus weil sie
deren kommunikation lesen konnten sie
knackten die ich je früher geräte diese
verschlüsseln die getippten oder
gemauerten nachrichten bevor sie
verschickt werden damit niemand sie
abfangen und mitlesen kann
doch nach dem kriegsende standen die
amerikaner vor einem problem
[Musik]
vorher die amerikanischen
nachrichtendienste mit mathematischen
verfahren mit guter kryptologie
viele kommunikation knacken können und
stellten dann auf einmal selbst da gibt
es ein schwedisches rené das macht schon
vier geräte die extrem schwer zu knacken
sind oder gar nicht lösbar sind das
genie doris hagel ihn die amerikaner
wollen ihn auf ihre seite ziehen seine
unknackbar frier geräte sollen nicht dem
feind in die hände geraten hagel ihn
gehört zu den experten wenn es um
sichere kommunikation geht vor dem
zweiten weltkrieg und auch noch in den
fünfzigern war es eher eine kleine zahl
von leuten die diese sehr spezielle
technik verstanden die konnten sich alle
so können sich auch die kryptologen der
us geheimdienste und boris h gelingt sie
schlagen ihm an dir vor er will ich
sofort ein
[Musik]
diese überwachte den weltweiten vertrieb
von hagel in maschinen um
sicherzustellen dass die sichersten
maschine nur an nato mitgliedstaaten und
andere befreundete regierungen verkauft
werden
das ist als ob eine kleine gruppe eine
spezielle magie keinen wirbel und die
sprechen sich ab diese magie
kontrolliert wird
die magie das ist die kryptologie das
herz einer chiffre maschine mithilfe
ausgefeilter algorithmen werden
nachrichten verschlüsselt und gehen so
als kauderwelsch durch die kanäle wer
die algorithmen kennt besitzt die macht
diese macht will boris hagel in den
amerikanern geben es gab natürlich auch
einen elementaren grund für die positive
einstellung gegenüber den vermeintlichen
staaten der grund nämlich dass die
vereinigten staaten das hitler regime in
die knie gezwungen haben
1952 zieht bubis hagel ihn in die
schweiz in der garage dieses hauses im
zug installiert er die erste werkstatt
seiner firma er nimmt sie crypto ag
in die schweiz kommt er nicht nur um
steuern zu sparen ihn stört in schweden
noch etwas anderes die strengeren
exportrestriktionen die neutrale und
liberale schweiz scheint ihn der ideale
standort für sein business wenn man an
heiklen geschäften wie die kryptographie
beteiligt war suchte man besser den
schutz eines neutralen landes mit
weniger moralischen skrupeln
die junge firma wächst rasant die
klügsten köpfe tüfteln an neuen geräten
schmieden ausgefeilte algorithmen man
verkauft in die ganze welt
ein patent nach dem anderen wird
angemeldet die firma genießt einen
exzellenten ruf
mitte der 60er jahre zählt sie bereits
180 mitarbeiter und in steinhausen
nehmen zug wird ein großzügiger
firmensitz erstellt
es ist für viele eine ehre bei der
krypto ag zu arbeiten das erzählt auch
bruno von a ein entwicklungsingenieur
der 27 jahre die vier geräte
mitgestaltet
die krypta das ist ein top modernes
firma
technologisch an der spitze
bald wird anerkannt als gute schief lief
es ist der fabrik sehr
diskrete breit 50 meter lang mit also
zwei elfmeter arbeitsplatz carlo machen
maskerade
planen können abstellung zu bieten
nur ein altes gefährt kam er
aus schweizer firma in eine neutrale
staat
unabhängig von großmächten so mehr tut
die ganze wald bislang
dass bruno von ah damals nicht weiß die
meisten schiffe ihre geräte die das werk
in steinhausen verlassen haben eine
eingebaute hintertür von gründervater
hagel ihn und den amerikanern ausgeheckt
den mitarbeitern gegenüber verschwiegen
die swiss made quality verkauft sich
äußerst gut die neutralität der schweiz
weil geradezu der garant für den
wirtschaftlichen erfolg der gruppe okay
bald stehen in vielen regierungsbüros in
botschaften und armee hauptquartieren
fernschreiber und funkanlagen
abgesichert mit verschlüsselungs geräten
der krypto ag
mit aufklärungsflugzeugen und ihren
riesigen ohren fangen die amerikaner
täglich tausende geheime botschaften aus
der luft alles was über crypto ag geräte
verschlüsselt wird sie können es mit
lesen
[Musik]
1967 übertraf das programm die kühnsten
erwartungen seiner erfinder
die zusammenarbeit mit den
geheimdiensten wird immer enger ein
essay und chemischen sich nun auch ein
wenn neue maschinen entwickelt werden
sie entwerfen die algorithmen die krypto
ag also boris hagel ihn übernimmt
ende der 60er jahre ist boris hagel ihn
schon längst im pensionsalter es stellt
sich die frage wie es weitergeht mit der
firma und dem geheimen deal
gab es natürlich einen potenziellen
nachfolger aber ein nachfolger der sehr
sehr dort nicht gemacht hat dass er die
schmutzigen geschäfte seines vaters
nicht weiterführen würde
ohg junior leitet das nord- und
südamerika geschäft ist die meiste zeit
weit weg von der firma äußert sich aber
immer wieder skeptisch
er galt als unberechenbare faktor im
spiel der wenn er die waren abmachungen
entdeckte versuchen könnte sie zu
sabotieren
schlussendlich entscheidet sich hagel
ein senior gegen seinen sohn und für
einen verkauf
es entsteht ein seilziehen zwischen
nachrichtendiensten der amerikanischen
cia dem westdeutschen bnd und dem
französischen geheimdienst
schlussendlich passiert das worüber die
welt bis heute spekuliert hat was aber
nie ganz ans licht gekommen ist dass
geheimdienst papier bringt endlich
klarheit der westdeutsche geheimdienst
bnd und die cia kaufen 1970 gemeinsam
die krypto ag
der verkauf wurde am vierten juni
abgeschlossen der verkaufspreis belief
sich auf 25 millionen schweizer franken
ab jetzt ist die firma fest in den
händen ausländischer geheimdienste gegen
aussen weiterhin getarnt als normale
schweizer firma
ein blick ins handelsregister zeigt
hagel in senior tritt 1970 sofort aus
allen ämtern zurück und seinem sohn beau
dem skeptiker wird die prokura
gestrichen
da gab es natürlich eine verschlungene
konstruktion über eine treuhandanstalt
in liechtenstein die gewinne wurden aus
liechtenstein dann nach münchen
transferiert dort von bnd mitarbeiter
abgeholt zur hälfte und seeleuten in
einer münchner tiefgaragen ihren
schlechten filmen und koffer
ausgehändigt
hagel in junior damals wohnhaft in
amerika war scheinbar der einzige
eingeweihte gegner dieses unheimlichen
bnd deals
[Musik]
aber im november 1970 kam wohl nur fünf
monate nach dem verkauf bei einem
verkehrsunfall ums leben es würde nicht
länger nötig sein gegenüber dem kripo ag
vorstand hinsichtlich der
besitzverhältnisse so viel vorsicht
walten zu lassen
selbst der vizepräsident des
bundesnachrichtendienstes ging davon aus
dass frage die nicht opfer eines unfalls
wird opfer eines nachrichtendienstlichen
mordes wurde
man erzählt sich hagel in senior hatte
noch viele jahre den tod seines sohnes
aufzuklären versucht erfolglos
die operation minerva um schwebt bis
heute ein schwer durchdringen baarer
mantel des schweigens
er redet als erster und einziger bernd
schmidbauer ehemaliger staatsminister
unter bundeskanzler helmut kohl
zuständig für die geheimdienste
ich würde sagen es war eine sehr
gelungene operation man hat information
bekommen die man nur auf einem solchen
weg erhalten konnte es ist wichtiger
denn je an informationen zu kommen
geheime pläne zu kennen
denn die narben von zwei kriegen sind
längst nicht verheilt die welt ist
geteilt in ost und west angst dominiert
die politik
die gesamtschau aber habe ich die das
übersicht hatten gezielt haben sie ja
mit anderen methoden gearbeitet die
nachrichtendienste in dem sie jemanden
mikrofon und das auto oder ins hemd oder
weiß der kuckuck was war ja viel
präziser weil unmittelbarer aber oben
einen überblick zu haben da wird ein
manöver angekündigt irgendwo ein manöver
das wir nicht
identifizieren können bedrohlich ja oder
nein dann sieht man den den verkehr
zwischen allen und dann weiß man was
sich abspielt in der welt so trägt die
kleine crypto ag dazu bei dass die
ausländischen geheimdienste im großen
stil wissen was sich wo abspielt in
steinhausen bricht derweil eine neue ära
an jetzt gehört die firma voll und ganz
der cia und dem bnd die neuen besitzer
bestimmen alles neue kaderleute werden
nun sogar in das minerva geheimnis
eingeführt direkt von der cia
so auch siegmar genannt mackie grützmann
ehefrau und tochter erinnern sich an den
familienausflug in die usa sie haben
damals natürlich keine ahnung worauf ihr
mann ihr vater sich einlässt
das war der eintritt es war für mich
natürlich faszinierend noch nie geflogen
für auch dass wir genau an schrauben
durch manhattan einem flughafen zum
anderen hubschrauber mit nur gesunden
meditieren ist beim lauf war
hubschrauber und da waren wir auch acht
tage allein in washington und mein mann
der war immer weg und er hat immer nur
gesagt ich hab' geschäftig besprechen er
hat mal gesagt glaube du hast du
irgendwie mehr abgeliefert werden zu
kultur habe habe er hat nicht gesagt
wohin das waren es war eine straße im
wald oder park und da war waren tor das
war bestimmt
20 30 meter breit und da habe ich ihn
abgeliefert und dann essen gegangen also
mit dem wissen heute denke ich dass der
see im darauf vorbereitet hat
was er zu tun hat in dieser firma
er wurde angeworben und eingeweiht um
die krypto arge kryptologen vor
misstrauischen kunden zu verteidigen
[Musik]
wickie kurzmann reist mit seinem
geschäftsleitungs kollegen zu kunden in
aller welt syrien afghanistan pakistan
ägypten gemeinsam lügen sie die kunden
an ihre geräte seien die abhör
sichersten auf dem markt es funktioniert
die krypto ag wird immer erfolgreicher
und so prägen diese manipulierten
maschinen die weltgeschichte mit
wohl auch den militärputsch in chile
dokumente aus dem bundesarchiv beweisen
die direktion der intelligenzia erwirbt
anfang der 70er jahre bewilligt durch
das militärdepartement für eine halbe
million franken crypto ag geräte
seit kurzem ist eine demokratisch
gewählte regierung an der macht eine
linke regierung unter salvador allende
er verlässt sich auf die neutralen
schweizer verschlüsselungs geräte um
abhörsicher zu kommunizieren doch die
usa wollen keine sozialistische
regierung in ihrer nähe mit
umfangreichen aktionen unterstützt die
cia einen militärputsch
1973 experten gehen davon aus dass das
abhören der krypto geräte den usa
wichtige vorteile verschafft
der putsch gelingt von einem tag auf den
anderen feld chile in eine diktatur es
folgen viele jahre gewaltsamer
herrschaft von augusto pinochets
andersdenkende werden gefoltert
verschleppt getötet
die informationen die die amerikaner und
auch die deutschen durch das abhören der
krypto verschlüsselungs geräte abfangen
können helfen den großmächten die welt
nach ihrem gusto zu gestalten
minerva beleuchtete die krisenherde
dieser welt
das war eine der dreistesten
skandalösesten operationen
wie als 100 länder der welt zahlt
milliarden um sich ihre eigenen
geheimnisse stehlen zu lassen eigentlich
ziemlich unverfroren
die krypto ag spielt ihr doppeltes spiel
immer professioneller die neuen
technologien erlauben immer
raffiniertere hintertürchen und die
kunden vertrauen gerade in politisch
heiklen zeiten der firma aus der
neutralen schweiz deren
eigenes forsch mit dem roten teppich
empfangen
es hat eben auch glaube ich gefallen
weil es so viel einsatz auf der ganzen
welt hat das merke ich dass mario dem
und stehe damit trat das
problem
diskutieren
die alte schreibmaschine
versteckt im hintersten winkel ihres
dachbodens malaika hug hat sie als
andenken an ihren vater aufbewahrt die
hug war viele jahre für die krypto ag
als verkäufer unterwegs auch er
berichtete oft wie er von generälen und
offizieren hofiert wurde darunter waren
auch diktatoren wie muammar gaddafi in
libyen
greta kaufen und dass er den dritten
gerät zeigen wie die gönnt und dass er
ja schule gemacht es sind sehr um höhere
offiziere sind
so fasst als wie ip
genieren fast aus wie
die haupt größer war saudi arabien
gefolgt von den ländern jugoslawien iran
italien indonesien argentinien irak
libyen jordanien und südkorea jedes
dieser länder war ein wichtiges
geheimdienst ziel
für die amerikanischen geheimdienste ist
das eine unglaublich wertvolle operation
es trägt zu einer ganzen reihe wichtige
erfolge bei
trick zu einem nahost-frieden satz
kommen bei
das war 1978 der nahostkonflikt spitzt
sich zu israel und ägypten bekriegen und
misstrauen sich verhandlungen zwischen
den ländern sind zäh bis zum auftritt
der usa als verhandlungsführerin
jimmy carter lädt den ägyptischen
präsidenten anwar as sadat und den
israelischen ministerpräsidenten
menachem begin zur sich nach camp date
ein
haben sie also mehr gehen sie haben an
wasserdampf die hassen sich die wollen
nicht miteinander sprechen also sind sie
in zwei verschiedenen zentren zwei
verschiedenen häusern sie haben
delegationen die schicken die
kommunikation hin und her theater muss
diese leute zusammenbringen links peter
gerber ägypten stand natürlich der
arabischen welt nicht alleine da und
musste sich bei staaten wie
saudi-arabien und anderen mitgliedern
der arabischen liga vergrößern
wie weit man in den verhandlungen gehen
darf und diese
verbesserungsprozesse ließen natürlich
über verschlüsselt und diplomatische
kommunikation sein schlie das bedeutet
jimmy carter spielt poker und kann alle
kann es sehen bekommt
der lang ersehnte frieden im nahen osten
ist zum greifen nah und us präsident
jimmy carter der held im minerva
dokument steht dazu auf seite 56
wie wertvoll war es
1979 während der camp david
verhandlungen zwischen israel und
ägypten ägyptens diplomatische
korrespondenz lesen zu können die
richtige antwort lautet unbezahlbar
die usa markieren in dieser zeit ihrer
rolle als weltpolizist immer stärker und
viele gestehen ihnen dies auch zu also
der armee war toll
[Musik]
der appell der westen ist gut
dass die amerikaner waren ja damals noch
eine überhöhte nation
in steinhausen glauben noch immer die
meisten mitarbeiter die legende dass sie
hier die unknackbar ssten die sichersten
verschlüsselungs geräte der welt
produzieren
manchmal kommt der direktor mit
bauplänen zu den ingenieuren und sagt
hier ich habe wieder einen plan von gott
erhalten da er nicht verraten darf woher
die mathematik die algorithmen stammen
doch einigen mitarbeitern wird die sache
langsam unheimlich
alfred gerät klammert und er wusste wie
sie funktionieren die
entwicklungsingenieure der krypta haben
nach bestem wissen und gewissen versucht
unlösbare jeffrey geräte zu bauen sich
war algorithmen zu basteln
dem
archiv der generator
und bewunderten amoklauf fang ich
begreife stand
direkt geräte und exakt wunderbar jetzt
mit
den
hals nach hause reisten mit dem
lochstreifen
der musiker gerät
im nachhinein wieder getan und feststeht
hat es anders aus dass da noch andere
lied das sie jetzt sind was da schief
irgendwann das ist komisch vor hoch die
einzige erklärung dafür kauft ist dass
die geräte manipulierten
sie wussten eigentlich
dass der höhere mächte in ihrer guten
technik beim gekosten haben
[Musik]
bei der entwicklung eines innovativen
gerät für militärs dem mcc 314 wird die
sache noch klarer bei jedem
entwicklungsschritt mischen sich
deutsche stellen ein wöchentlich fahren
in steinhausen mitarbeiter des deutschen
nachrichtendienstes vor getarnt als
berater von siemens und verlangen
änderungen der entwicklungschef schöpft
verdacht und rechnet die pläne über das
wochenende genau durch
doch ein mitarbeiter der die hintertür
kennt den versteckten zugang auf die
hochgradige verschlüsselung ist nicht
gern gesehen bei den wahren besitzer der
firma den ausländischen geheimdiensten
er war die minerva geheimnis auf die
spur gekommen und es war nicht sicher
bei ihm
der entwicklungschef ist von einem tag
auf den anderen weg
foto nicht das passiert
und mehr hätte einfach den skater
damals zufällig also
als ex entlassen wurde hatte er ohne das
wissen der partner beim schweizer
justizministerium vorwürfe gegen die
krypto ag wegen manipulation von geräten
vorgebracht
[Musik]
wenn es bern nicht sowieso schon längst
wusste spätestens jetzt wissen es die
behörden sie werden über den verdacht
informiert dass ausländische
nachrichtendienste über eine schweizer
firma spionage betreiben wie reagieren
die schweizer behörden darauf nehmen sie
die vorwürfe ernst sind sie gar
alarmiert wir suchen antworten im
bundesarchiv in den fischen abteilung
finden wir den beleg der entlassene
entwicklungschef erklärte bereits ende
der 70er jahre den behörden die geräte
seien mit manipulierten schlüssel
generatoren versehen worden womit die
anhöhe dienste der brd und usa die
möglichkeit erhielten die botschaft zu
dechiffrieren
die behörden erstellen den fall
die spur verliert sich mit der hilfe der
mitarbeiter des bundesarchivs stoßen wir
auf eine einzelne mysteriöse karteikarte
zu finden darauf ist keine information
aber eine instruktion also ich habe hier
ein fischer und ich will bezeichnung aus
lehre als lade fischer
und da was ist normal wenn
man bundesanwaltschaft beobachtet
pflichtet sind vielleicht mit meiner
verwies auf die entsprechende dosis
hat keine idee große fische biker aktion
code bei anfragen nicht erwähnen dass
diese existiert gegen gegen meldung an
ldk von dem antrag eingegangen ist
was die behörden sonst zum fall code
hatten bleibt ein geheimnis die suche
endet in einer sackgasse weitere
dokumente zur aktion code sind
verschonen man muss davon ausgehen dass
sie schweizer sicherheitsbehörden die
nachrichtendienstlichen einfluss
anwählen und cad auf die kultur ag sehr
genau kann
die bundespolizei wurde allerdings aktiv
und ging den anschuldigungen des
entlassenen crypto ag entwicklungschefs
nach dass ich vor mir
das ist service geschnittene szenen als
grad vom land wo er hat selber
manipuliert sie
israel und der befindliche schloss sie
das ist eine kleine wiese darauf gibt
dass der manipulationen vorgenommen
handfeste beweise fehlen oder werden
nicht weiter gereicht trotzdem ist davon
auszugehen dass in bern spätestens jetzt
einzelne personen kenntnis von dieser
spionage operation haben
[Musik]
ich halte die arbeit der schweizer
dienste sehr gut aber in dieser zeit und
ich nehme an dass sie nicht uninformiert
waren die offizielle schweiz will
offenbar keinen eklat prüft aber ihre
eigenen geräte die sich als sicher
herausstellen laut ea erhält die schweiz
seit anfang nicht manipulierte geräte
ohne hintertür eine art unausgesprochene
die
also lässt man die krypto ag in
steinhausen weiter gewähren auch in der
firma verfliegt die aufregung rasch neue
geheimnisträger übernehmen die späten
70er und frühen 80er sind rauschen die
geschäftsjahre die krypto ag wird
weltmarktführer und den mitarbeitern
wird einiges geboten
[Musik]
und ich mache mich
sind
schiffe klingt wir waren unheimlich oft
ein zu zu festen und essen und irgendwie
immer hat hier weg ja das schöne
slowakei waren die mitarbeiter werden
umgehend ein firmeneigenes fußballfeld
ein tennisplatz entstehen sogar ein
segelboot wird angeschafft
es ist auch die zeit in der hans bühler
angestellt wird der enthusiastische
weltenbummler und funkamateur gilt als
verkaufsgenie einer der mit den
schwierigsten kunden umzugehen weiß sagt
auch minerva
bühler war einer der aufsteigenden
sterne der krypto ag
er liebt seinen interessanten und
aufregenden job der ihn in die ferne
welt bringt allein den iran besucht er
25 mal für die krypto ag
doch die mitarbeiter wissen nicht
welcher gefahr sie sich aussetzen hans
bühler wird es später im iran
schmerzhaft erfahren
was den angestellten verheimlicht wird
sie sind nicht nur für ihre schweizer
firma unterwegs sondern auch für
ausländische geheimdienste
[Musik]
wie wir diese verkäufer sind nicht in
die operation ein gewand sie wissen
nicht was sie verkaufen sie werden
faktisch als agenten eingesetzt ohne zu
ahnen dass die agenten sind identisch
er weiß dass er quasi ein agent ist mit
kietzmann
angestellt um mit seiner fachkompetenz
die fragen skeptischer kunden zu
überstrahlen doch seine doppelrolle
belastet ihn bald ich musste ihnen
immerhin zürich abholen und da hatte ich
oft dann gemerkt er eine alkoholfahne
also ich denke
dass es da
irgendwas vielleicht betäubt hat
die familie sieht wie er leidet ohne zu
wissen warum diese stuft ihn bald als
unbrauchbar für die operation als
befreiend meinung share the secret that
i couldn't quatsch oder
das sind total assad fündig
niki grissmann muss immer wieder
misstrauische kunden täuschen auch das
damalige jugoslawien hat die gerade für
viele hunderttausend franken chf 4
geräte erworben das neueste modell
involviert sind sogar leute aus der
armeespitze dann kommt ein anruf aus
belgrad
das problem
die rücklagen haben wie viele andere
staaten
eigene kultur kapazitäten entwickelt
experten herangezogen die sehr schnell
erkannt haben dass sie von der coupe de
ag
unsere geräte bekommen hatten der
schlamm 16
die jugoslawische armee droht wenn die
ingenieure keine lösungen präsentierten
würden sie das schmutzige geheimnis
enthüllen
krisensitzung der firmenleitung
einen monat später reist bruno von a
nach belgrad mit lösungsvorschlägen im
koffer er verrät ihnen wie die hintertür
zu gemacht das gerät sicher gemacht
werden kann
damit gehört
bis
der jugoslawienkrieg losgegangen ist
noch kraft und
geschossen
leipzigs mitglied zu mir und fragte mich
wie randy grad ausgeliefert noch
jugoslawien in der hopfenstadt
elisabeth stähler
probierten das löst zur umsetzung und
dann ist es halt nirgendwo
spätestens jetzt wird brunner vor klar
dass hier noch andere ziemlich große
mächte ihre finger im spiel haben dass
geheimdienste versuchen die
kommunikation der serben während der
kriegswirren abzuhören und dies nicht
geht eine schwere bürde für die
eingeweihten führungskräfte wie micky
grützmann er der genau weiß was im
hinterzimmer alles abgesprochen wird
welch abgekartetes spiel hier eigentlich
läuft er musste rechtfertigen dass das
ja alles in ordnung ist er musste genügt
es war seine aufgabe
das konnte er nicht
daran ist er kaputt gegangen inadäquat
mit großmann hält dem druck nicht stand
er wird gefeiert zu hause erzählt er
lediglich dass er die betrügereien der
amerikaner nicht mehr aushält
später dann hier in stuttgart da der das
dann gesagt dass die krypto mit dem cia
und bnd
zusammenarbeitet
belastend ist für mich dass man nicht
nur dass er zum lügen gezwungen war er
hat wohl auch gespürt was er tut kann
welt politische auswirkungen haben
maschinen die er verkauft stehen
plötzlich im zentrum von
auseinandersetzungen
hinzu kommt dass die operation immer
skrupelloser wird man verkauft die
krypto geräte nun auch an befreundete
länder den vatikan italien irland
spanien und sogar an die uno ich kann
feststellen wenn es um krieg und frieden
ging dass bestimmte methoden einfach
notwendig waren die aktion hat sicher
dazu beigetragen dass die welt ein stück
sicherer
geblieben ist und man viele
informationen hat die auf anderen wegen
nicht beschafft werden konnten
doch diese sogenannten beschafften
informationen stellen die geheimdienste
auch immer wieder vor moralische die
lamas zum beispiel im fall von
argentinien auch das argentinische
militärregime unter general theory de la
ist kunde der schweizer firma durch die
krypto geräte können bnd und ce aus
erster hand erfahren wie die
argentinische militär runter mit
regime-gegnern umgeht wie sie
verschleppt misshandelt und ermordet
werden
dokumente gehen wahrscheinlich weiter
als alles was wir bisher gesehen haben
wenn es darum geht zu zu geben wie viel
die westlichen regierungen von diesen
gräueltaten wussten und es ist
überraschend dass es da nicht mehr
widerstand der europäer und amerikaner
gab gegen diese vorgänge in argentinien
woche für woche werden gefangene in
flugzeuge gepfercht und über dem offenen
meer lebendig hinausgeworfen so sterben
tausende
dem brutalen regime fallen mehr als
30.000 menschen zum opfer
seit über 40 jahren demonstrieren die
mütter der verschleppten und ermordeten
ein protest auch gegen den westen der
nichts unternahm um das morden zu
stoppen
nora moralist der gordini assist von
anfang an dabei ihr sohn carlos wurde
1977 entführt
die regierungen wussten vom horror der
folter den entführungen von babys von
schwangeren frauen sie wussten dass und
unternahmen nichts um die situation zu
beenden
die diktatur dauerte acht bis neun jahre
wegen der komplizenschaft dieser länder
die mit der diktatur geschäfte machten
auf ziviler kirchlicher und ökonomischer
ebene
ihr sohn bleibt bis heute verschwunden
es ist nicht ungewöhnlich dass
geheimdienstler in einem schrecklichen
moralischen dilemma stecken handelst du
verrätst du deine operation dann gibt es
keine informationen
auch er ist ein rädchen in der groß
angelegten geheimdienst operation
so absolut ist das wo die hug sicher
nicht bewusst aber zu sehen was auf der
welt alles geschieht und zu wissen dass
crypto ag geräte an vielen dieser
unruhigen orte im einsatz stehen lässt
ihm keine ruhe
schlussendlich es hat mit ihm da also es
hat ihn beschäftigt und er hat sich
immer wohl gefühlt dass er es kaum
verkaufen wenn er weiß dass da bewusst
rar gemacht wurde nicht obwohl er nicht
genau gewusst was da gemacht worden ist
das ist ein schlussendlich alles lesen
sie wie so dass er
glück da eigentlich dann der rücken
zugewendet hat und ich bin im nachhinein
was alles passiert ist
froh dass er das gemacht hat
gerade dann im 21 aber das mit dem hans
bühler passiert ist kann ich nur
verdankt um ein gewinn für die
verhaftung der schweizer geschäftsmannes
hans bühler in iran belastet die
beziehungen zwischen der schweiz und der
islamischen republik iran schwer hans
bühler der star verkäufer er geht auf
routinebesuch zu seinem stammkunden dem
iranischen militär die iraner die sich
politisch besonders alleine und isoliert
fühlen vertrauen seit vielen vielen
jahren der krypto ag den geräten aus der
neutralen schweiz
der iran war der lukrativste abnehmer
manipulierte crypto geräte weil der iran
mit vorliebe bei minerva kaufte waren
die iranischen ziele zu 80 bis 90
prozent lesbar nach einer chiffre geräte
präsentation wird hans bühler verhaftet
in ein militärgefängnis gebracht und
intensiv verhört vorwurf spionage
für die mitarbeiter der krypto ag ein
schock auch weil sich die firma gegen
aussen wenig um müller zu kümmern
scheint ihn hängen lässt wir haben unser
augenmerk erstmals darauf gerichtet dass
hans bühler eine bessere unterbringung
im iran im gefängnis erhielt
jetzt wird ihnen klar dass im grunde
jeder verkäufer der krypto ag eine
potenzielle geiser ist ein potenzieller
gefangenen jemand dir gefoltert werden
könnte parteien schließen und roche
und bnd befürchten dass die operation
auffliegt ihr großes gemeinsames
geheimnis mehr war ans licht kommt
das wäre das ende
was würde geschehen wenn man bücher in
einem iranischen gefängnis verrotten
lassen würde wie viel wusste er über die
besitzverhältnisse der firma
die täter vor einer ebene nicht er hat
keine kenntnis verhindert werden das
ungewisse kunden konkrete zurück was
passiert mit ihm die dünne und wenn ihr
flug und was ist ja für mensch noch das
verhöre sowie gegangen da bist mir in
der bestohlenen raus oder hat stehen
begleitet jetzt
bekanntlich und pflegt die wollten
eigentlich von brüder das eingeständnis
dass die cocteau ag von
nachrichtendiensten das licht
nachrichtendiensten manipulierte geräte
verkauft und das hätte natürlich nicht
nur dem iran bewegt sondern die iraner
wusste genau dass perfekt die gesamte
arabische welt
nach der ersten gerichtsverhandlung
kommt endlich bewegung in den fall die
iraner fordern eine million dollar
kaution damit bühler nach hause kann
doch der damalige geschäftsleiter der
krypto ag michael gruppe will nicht
zahlen während sich auch die cia weigert
wird der bnd nervös und entscheidet
falls notwendig würde deutschland die
gesamte million dollar alleine zahlen
der bundesnachrichtendienst musste alles
unternehmen damit seine verwicklungen
die firma nicht offenkundig wurde das
heißt da musste auch dieses geld
hinlegen und so geschieht es auch
deutschland nimmt die millionen dollar
in die hand und kaufte hans bühler frei
nach über neun monaten haft lassen um
die iraner endlich gehen ein
gezeichneter mann kommt am flughafen
zürich an
in einem späteren rundschau beitrag
beschreibt hans bühler seine
traumatischen erlebnisse im teheraner
gefängnis
sie wollen mit unseren weg morgen
zufrieden firma
firma crypto in jeder für nachrichten
schlechte
spiele gymnasien aufbau die frau von
schlüsseln code von der firma die
furchtbarsten die liegewiese sich auch
für andere ideen und dann am besten wenn
sie jetzt nicht rettet mittag sicher
nicht ganz meter gast den wir in den
genuss kommen und dann werden sie sich
im fokus man hat mich ein
bloßer was zur folge hat die den
vortagen dann bin ich dann auch und dann
wieder unterwegs ist für mich ist dass
sie wie
immer auf die letzte seite meint
richards doch hans bühler entkommt dem
horror
in steinhausen wird er feierlich
willkommen geheißen die krypto ag
veranstaltet einen apéro für ihren star
verkäufer die geschäftsleitung alle sind
da
doch kurze zeit später wird bühler
entlassen das vertrauensverhältnis sei
gestört wird sich mal vorstellen aber
sicherlich sehr schwer vorstellen sie
sind je nach umfang nichts wissen nicht
warum
und mit high und ich habe das firma
unsere abbildung wir gemacht haben
fragen für die ganze belegschaft aber
hinter das andere gesicht
hans bühler kann es nicht fassen kann
nicht verstehen seine fragen werden
dringender von tag zu tag er beginnt zu
recherchieren und kommt einem teil der
wahrheit hinter der krypto ag auf die
spur
bei seiner recherche kann er auf die
unterstützung seines guten freundes wo
die hug zählen
sie fest vor knoten am hans roth auf
irgendeine möglichkeit gibt dass mit ihm
kann helfen die vorgeschriebenen
nationalrat die kontaktaufnahme mit
mitglied in der vermeintlichen hoffnung
dass es irgendeine bis
1994 schreibt journalist res strehle mit
bühler ein buch darin beschuldigt dieser
die krypto ag mit geheimdiensten zu
kooperieren
diese anschuldigungen lösen eine mediale
welle aus die firma ihrerseits bemüht
sich kräftig das bild einer unabhängigen
und unbeeinflussten firma zu wahren
geschäftsführer michael grube stellt
sich in der rundschau den heiklen fragen
und lügt den journalisten gabeli direkt
ins gesicht die geheime aktionären ist
die bundesrepublik deutschland bzw
der bundesnachrichtendienst was sagen
sie dazu das ist natürlich völliger
unsinn sie haben also nun gar nichts am
hut mit nachrichtendiensten nur als
kunden natürlich und von manipulationen
kann keine rede sein
manipulation kann nur jemand behaupten
der sehr naiv diesen dingen gegenüber
steht unsere geräte sind nicht
manipulierbar wie die see in minerva
dokument auf seite 80 schreibt ist sie
stolz auf michael grubes leistung im
fernsehen
er wies die vorwürfe unverblümt zurück
groupies auftritt war glaubwürdig und
marc das programm gerettet haben
aufatmen bei den hintermännern der
krypto ag die gefahr scheint abgewendet
doch hans bühler geht mit seinen
vorwürfen auch nach bern
jürg bühler leitete damals die
ermittlungen der bundespolizei der
heutige vize direktor des
nachrichtendienstes
erinnert sich
die bundespolizei nimmt vorabklärungen
auftrifft rund 20 aktuelle und ehemalige
mitarbeiter auch bruno von er wird in
ein café bestellt sei ein
hintergrundgespräch und steht vor einem
großen dilemma
oder silly nett wenn man verändert
werden
kann wenn man nie zuvor seit der nach
istanbul ohne koffer die sie beobachtet
es hin und her in der schweiz sehr genau
und zittert wie im minara war dokument
zu lesen ist
the missing information der innenseite
genau was passiert ist mit
mitte gerät eigentlich doch die
rundschau konnte mit mehreren ehemaligen
mitarbeitern sprechen alle berichten von
einer seltsamen stimmung bei diesen
befragungen als ob es die
bundespolizisten nicht wirklich hätten
hören wollen ähnlich empfand des bruno
von a als er sich schlussendlich
entschied zu reden
der bundespolizei seit das es ermöglicht
hinderte lebt das halle saale bei
statiker mit hjk wo sie hingehört was
eine hintertür erwartet je näher
beschrieben tatsache ist sie das ist
jetzt können oder wie
präzise auskunft
unterstützt das gerücht und hörensagen
wenn er keine genügende
verdachtsmomenten von der bundespolizei
sei
dass es ein mögliches ende geht und
wenn
wenn sie mir wenn die bundesanwaltschaft
mir
garantiert dass
sie
verhindere das glück das sie
gerade wenn wir die uns
etliche der kryptologie mitarbeiter
packen bei den befragungen aus und
scheinen auf taube ohren zu stoßen auch
fahren die bundespolizisten nach
steinhausen
[Musik]
die buko beamten besuchten die fabrik
und sprachen mit gruppe und anderen
schienen aber nicht sehr daran
interessiert zu sein in die tiefe zu
gehen es war eindeutig ein pro forma
besuch
[Musik]
nicht
weiß nicht wie er mitteilte hat sie aber
besser
wenn wir in strophen fahrer kann hat der
hat man lange die mittel zur verfügung
hat das ist klar aber nach astrotv muss
man schlechter führung eröffnen
für den geheimdienst experten gibt es
mindestens einen grund anzunehmen dass
die schweizer behörden gar nichts
herausfinden durften
jedenfalls nicht offiziell
hört sind die schweizer bundespolizei
der schweizer nachrichtendienst oder der
verteidigung von ist da
offiziell die auffassung vertreten die
krypto ag ist eine tochter von bnd und
ca und sie verkauften manipulierte
geräte die schweizer behörden hätten das
unternehmen schließen lassen
das wäre natürlich die absolute
kriegserklärung an ziehen die un eine
see gewesen das konnte sich die schweiz
überhaupt nicht leisten
ja ja
irgendwann fragt die bundespolizei nicht
mehr weiter und die bundesanwaltschaft
entscheidet ist bei der voruntersuchung
zu belassen so drückt es wird still um
den fall crypto ag aus bernhard wohnung
von anni wieder etwas
die bundesanwaltschaft
schweigen ist gold
für die schweiz scheint die sache
erledigt doch in deutschland macht man
sich gedanken wie weiter mit dieser
ultra heiklen operation
bernd schmidbauer hatte damals den
bundesnachrichtendienst unter sich er
sagt für sein land stand zu viel auf dem
spiel deutschland war frisch wieder
vereint dieses neue bild wollte man
schützen
in der abwägung des risikos mit solchen
maßnahmen und dem aufkommen der fairness
staaten gegenüber anderen staaten
gegenüber bei abnehmender bedrohung war
es eine von uns richtige entscheidung
dass wir
neue wege gehen und dass wir über
solche operation oder dass wir mit
solchen operation nicht in die zukunft
gehen wollen
1993 verkauft der deutsche
nachrichtendienst seinen teil der takkt
ag an die cia sie ist ab jetzt alleinige
besitzerin der firma
in zürich muss sich hans bühler vor
gericht verantworten die krypto ag will
ihm verbieten will wieder öffentlich
anschuldigungen zu machen einen tag vor
der definitiven verhandlung einigt man
sich außergerichtlich bühler erhält
schweigegeld seither hat er kaum mehr
geredet
malaika hucks vater hat noch lange dafür
gekämpft dass das dunkle geheimnis der
krypto ag ans licht kommt vor vier
jahren ist er verstorben
ein wenig gerechtigkeit sehen kann und
es hat ihm hoffe dass er dann
schlussendlich nicht wahrheit
ans licht bringen und
niki grissmann stirbt jung die krypto
zeit hinterlässt ihn als gebrochenen
mann er erholt sich nie wieder seine
familie erfährt erst im minerva papier
was er wohl durchlitten hat auch später
noch
er hat gesagt tretet nicht so viel über
die krypto wir werden
beobachtet gar nichts da sogar nächster
zeit auch dass das porträt oder so das
hätte gar nicht veränderten das hat er
wirklich gesagt name gedacht es ist eine
sucht kopf der spinnt sich das heim an
auch spaß zusammen mehr als gedacht der
spinnt man
hat es nicht ernst genommen
was tun wenn ein anfänglich von rauch
hans bühler der weltenbummler verlässt
die schweiz nie wieder
im dezember 2018 stirbt auch er
wahrscheinlich ohne jemals die ganze
wahrheit erfahren zu haben
und der gründervater doris hagel ihn er
stirbt 1983 und hinterlässt seine
memoiren in einem safe sie werden in 13
jahren öffentlich nun ist ihm minar war
zuvor gekommen
kurz vor seinem tod soll einmal gesagt
haben ich bin der größte spion des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts